so what's this Uber story
um oh where the guy said that I uh
slapped you're gonna fight with an Uber
or something I didn't get a fight with
anything what happened with this play in
the air for us yeah so there's a guy
there's sort of a
um and really we shouldn't spend any
time at all talking about controversy
because I thought that the big thing
about the show was like helping people
yeah I don't know anything about the
Uber store is it controversial if we
don't we don't have to go there no it
was just you know that was such a
difficult time in American history when
it was like Hillary versus Trump
I don't know if the Uber story happened
a week ago yeah people are like uber
story TJ so let me ask them about the
Uber store and so this guy kind of
really got into the
um
you know the Hillary Clinton he was a
trump supporter and I was like well you
know I don't think that's the right
decision another Uber driver coming up
with that [ __ ] you're like what the [ __ ]
are you my Uber driver yeah and yeah
he's the Uber driver and I didn't
understand I wouldn't if I was driving I
would never bring up that stuff but he
really started baiting me and being like
well you made us fake if you gave money
to Hillary Clinton then that's that's an
error you made a mistake oh great it was
really it got really intense and I was
with Kate and so finally I just wouldn't
take the bait I was just not getting
into it and then sort of towards the end
of it
um
he kind of
realized who I was oh really
and he was already mad at me because I
wasn't like engaging
and then he dropped us off at our place
and we were kind of getting ready to go
in we hung out I think instead of a
cigarette or something at outside
um our spot and then like these cops
rolled through they were like hey this
guy said that you like hit him and I was
like Wow and they were like yeah I said
you slapped him and he wants to make a
citizen's arrest wow and I was like is
that even a real thing you know it's and
the cop was like not really but wow and
so
they of course they you know they had to
go through the procedure so I went
actually I went downtown
and uh then they let me go and they kind
of were like
um
a citizen's arrest isn't real but we you
know we have to just do paperwork on it
so then of course this dude right and I
really can't talk about this no it's all
good
um yeah in fact I'm done talking about
that guy but I want to tell you guys
that in general yeah it's pretty easy to
say something that's not true about a
celebrity and there's no recourse and so
then he threatened me with the sorry in
general people sometimes can be
threatened with the civil suit and then
you would have to and so some people
kind of you know if you if you were to
look into it with a private investigator
or something like that
um some people this is how they kind of
make a living
so if you look at their history they've
brought civil suits on how many people
on usually it's corporations because the
corporations will settle pay out
immediately they don't care they
actually have breakage for that they
have like money set aside for that so if
you like that clip click right here to
watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
[Music]